you know it's about to happen what do we
do who fight the whole gang is ready to
rumble in Captain America Civil War and
this is FBI Chris Evans is taking on
Iron Man himself Robert Downey jr. and
nischelle Turner was first on the sever
all the crazy action watch closely
because the fight choreography the super
stunts only et has them for you Tony
Stark and I have opposing views captain
you seem a little defensive and it
results in a little bit of conflict
sometimes I want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
it's team Downey versus team Evans and
it's war you just need Captain America's
solo mob leave me I'll take all the help
like heading team Evans is Captain
America himself joined by Anthony Mackie
war veteran Falcon nobody's head has
been you know filled with the idea of
being a celebrity the one celebrity in
the Marvel world
don't behind the eyes for the interview
also on Team Evans former baddie
recently converted to the Avengers
Elizabeth Olsen the Scarlet Witch her
role model is actually on Team Downey
the Black Widow Scarlett Johansson I
want to know what it feels like to fight
like that really bad just like what it
feels like in my body to physically be
able to do
so what you still feel like a new kid
I feel less like the new kid I feel far
more comfortable this time around yeah
is there a bit of hazing process like
what happily I feel like you know lo
Olsen we we bullied her a lot I'm not
planning on taking you alive
taking the high fall another Evans
teammate the former assassin Winter
Soldier the competition for best stunt
work is fierce and after work in Atlanta
the competition for best dance moves is
heated to not trying to brag but I can
bring it back I can bring back you can
challenge we can walk in any time with
Larry so don't worry dude Bobby don't be
Peggy out of my mayweather you don't
want your drama you don't want it
dance-off all right all right all right